welcome to this video playing pop I hear
okay before but one hundred percent
would then move en Popeye who is that no
name yeah this is in fact the best line
for black he seems to know where that
exactly like that that's how it is
played so let's see I think c4d 5s
there's a very crazy line with the rook
sacrifice rupiah aid sometimes you can
do and bishops on before so okay I'm
talking nonsense here let's just play
that game and I will do some some
overview review whatever on the
orangutan in the opening review after
after when this week is completed so um
yep Bishop f5 queen bee three years
maybe not before
may we have to start with that move
threatening a form wow really I thought
that would misplace stuff now and I'm
wrong yeah okay the night is misplaced
um but um on a six but my structure is a
complete wreck so let's not be so quick
IAM think for a moment III should be
three okay
okay that's not good but i think the
relatively best thing to do
I have no other square you have to be
sometimes you just have to be modest in
your in your position and be glad that
you're not getting wiped out quickly it
wasn't a good good way to play before I
really underestimated Bishop g4 quite a
bit okay so here and going for Knight f3
I actually think that this is not I mean
it's not good but it's not not lost or
anything just uncomfortable maybe you
can somehow poor matt is bad I'm a
natural optimist but it's really is a
bad position d3 is weak d 4 is the
weakness he's got active pieces yeah
that's a simple simple movement probably
something that I also would have would
have considered so let's see okay yep
this is the weakness
so the the way to go is so something
with a four a five would be nice if I
get that in
well I that that I did not expect let's
take to activate the Queen I'm not
saying it's bad it's just that I didn't
didn't have that on the agenda I was
thinking slowish play I actually have a
really good really good run here with
this offbeat openings to 460 is a really
high rating for my standards yeah so I'm
threatening default now it's a bit
awkward okay so look you one
still cannot take ya all of a sudden I
am rather active here on the on the
e-file
got more time that since I've been worse
and worse in this position in this game
sorry I've been worse in this position
as a somewhat strange way to phrase it
so mmm-hmm group e7 I Queens you form
not a good idea
okay let's play quick move
so the group is 64 some maybe Luke is 6
roop d3 fields Phil it's dangerous like
when g-form something like that I have
some some kind of player definite
definite counter play
still maybe you can take it up to three
ok check the night no yeah I have rupee
8i it's not great it's not great
I thought there should be some kind of
tactic I kind of relied on that okay i
guess i have to check it's not great but
after okay and now i'm changing I guess
I looked you one time morning may be
here
check I can take with the Queen up check
that was stupid very stupid way and play
it
check
check sorry a position is so good for
him even that somewhat strange play the
gelatin very much check check check
check check so it's a troll check yeah I
should have really gone from the rook
and check Stanley so I got the same
eight who Wow okay that was a ride yeah
he really outplayed me there no the
opening is say yeah this is this is one
of the this is one way to play a deaf
and get white under pressure so
interesting maybe just D for something
this is this is not a good idea probably
I already you know I simply I didn't see
that which is stupid it's just that
whatever is the what the what else
situation and here I'm just clearly
worse and struggling yeah still you can
fight but if I've was surprising but it
seems ok i really wonder here here I
felt I'm in decent shape yeah equal is
the engines evaluation here and g4 and
white is better wow what nah I didn't
consider that move
g-form yeah candidate moves it is the
candidate of course I'm attacking the
snide best move seems to be a rookie to
bishops III rookie form with the slight
advantage for wine okay whatever now kg
was kind of irrelevant I didn't I mean
it's not irrelevant I didn't see it at
all so this yeah i was thinking i should
have something here but i don't already
don't and now he check check just had
somebody who can camp he really miss
played it totally shack here this check
he could have could have chatted much
better let's let's have a look makia
check yeah he shan't looked it to us you
have to I'm sorry rook t2 to activate
that rook and take stuff to take pawns
here here take those pawns yeah it was a
bit lucky to get this draw here thanks
for watching